[Music]
craig's in jacksonville florida hi craig
how are you
good sir how are you doing today better
than i deserve what's up
doing good and it's a very it's an honor
to finally meet you and sorry i'm just a
little nervous um how can we help
i had a quick question um i was trying
to figure out i guess how i would stay
motivated during the baby step two um
i've been listening to you for about a
year through all your youtube videos and
podcasts and i actually i was
listening to some of the videos where i
called you today and that's what
encouraged me to call um
i'm currently again working on baby step
two i've probably paid about thirty five
thousand out of the sixty thousand
dollars in debt so far way to go and
i'm just kind of hitting a
an emotional
like mental and motivation
speed bump in this process
why do you think that is
well i just have a bunch of stuff on my
mind on what the career path i have
family issues going on my health and
everything so things have just kind of
taken a toll
over this whole year of grinding out
through this debt paying journey that
i'm on what's wrong with your health
well i have congestive heart failures um
since i've been since i was 26 i'm i'm
30 years old now so that that that did
not change
no no sir okay what's wrong with your
family
um my mother and father actually
have split up and now kind of
reworking their relationship so that's
kind of a cause too on everything
because i actually
stay with family member because of the
health issue i have
so you stay with one of them
i i stay at my uh grandmother's house
she bought the house when my when we
moved here in florida and i've been
staying there so your parents are not in
your
in your space every day
but they're they're going through their
own crap right
they are and my father tends to
use me as a crutch while i'm going
through what i'm going through and
sometimes it's very hard
yeah
okay and then you said you have a career
path issue
yes i'm currently a manager at a local
walgreens i work with i make about 31
000 a year
and
i'm blessed to have a job because i was
working at a different job before
coveted and then i switched back to this
job so and i'm just kind of not
really happy where i'm at because of the
amount i make
and it has got me through the first year
of me paying my
debt that i have but i've just kind of
felt like a slow
you know slowly my motivation starting
to hit rock bottom that makes sense
yeah because here's what's happening you
feel like this job's happening to you
you're not happening to yet you feel
like your parents mess is happening to
you you're not happening to it and the
heart thing is happening to you and
obviously you can't happen to it
you don't get to control that one
uh but these things are
uh controlling you
because you're allowing them to
yes sir
the parents mess
um
and your job mess
so you have the uh here's the thing it's
hard to have a sense of power over your
money when you have a sense of
powerlessness
in key relationships and powerlessness
in your career
yes sir they it's you know because it's
sucking what confidence you're you gain
a little confidence over here in the
money thing
like you paid off 35 000 that's really
good
but then it gets sick it's like your dad
and mom come along with a confidence uh
syringe and remove it
craig how long did it take to pay off
the 35
um i actually started last july and
that's including working at my job with
overtime and side gigs here and there
dude you've been living off nothing
that's impressive yeah i've literally
every two weeks i literally live off 150
in beans and rice rice and beans
literally wow
well on the health side that's something
you've got to manage that's obviously
not something we can just fix overnight
on the parent side it may require a
boundary with dad and a hard
conversation say dad listen
you need to find a good therapist a
counselor who can help walk you through
this i can't be that for you and on the
career side you can go be a manager
somewhere else you can start applying
today and probably make way more than
31.
yes sir
and so if you have that pep in your step
going i'm in control i can do this and
worst case you're doing this for one
year longer why'd you start the baby
steps to begin with
because
i wanted that financial freedom i
remember not having any debt having
money in the bank
um
you know able to buy something i want it
not go you know take like a car payment
or anything out but just having that
financial freedom and not that burden
you know you know what the problem with
a free book is
nobody reads them
because they were free nobody paid for
it you didn't pay for it but i'm gonna
give you two free books anyway on the
risk that i can get you to read them
i'm gonna give you paycheck to purpose
by ken coleman
so you get up on top of this career
thing and you start happening to it
instead of it happening to you and i'm
going to give you own your past change
your future from dr john doloni so you
can begin to have some tools
to work with mom and dad and say i love
you
but i can't fix this
i'm actually the kid
you're actually the parent
i can't fix this
and so
uh only the strong can help the weak and
you are not strong enough to carry your
dad right now
so him being uh using you as a crutch
he's got a rubber crutch he's going to
hit the floor
so uh and you're both going down
so you you know you've got to love him
uh but not be carrying around his stuff
you're carrying around all of his
burdens instead of him carrying them
and you feel stuck over at the job
because you haven't done anything about
getting unstuck
so i'm going to give you both books and
uh they're two different things but this
all comes back to craig you taking power
you taking uh
george's word agency over your life in
these areas
and uh when you do you're gonna get some
energy back for getting out of debt but
right now you got these two three
negative drains pulling you down while
you've got one area you're being
successful in that is very difficult for
anyone my man
well dave i'm gonna add in one more gift
in case he gets sick of reading craig
i'm gonna send you financial peace
university you can watch those videos it
also will include every dollar the
premium version so you can make a plan
for every dollar coming in and attack
this debt faster because i don't want
you to have to sacrifice longer than you
have yeah you know that's good and get
try to find one of the financial peace
groups in your area and join it get
connected let's get some human beings in
the room with you
who are excited that all showed up
that'll hold you accountable they're not
going to put up a whining but they also
in the other side are going to love you
and just say hey man you know you can do
this they'll incur encouragement
accountability we all need in areas
where we're struggling so yeah we'll
plug into all of that so we're dude
we're going to load you up with
resources
uh because it's it's easy to
to uh
have this many things coming at you
that are stealing power in so many
different areas it's easy to feel
powerless
the interesting thing is you're not
that you can just decide today i'm not
carrying my father's stuff around he
gets to carry his own stuff
i can apply for him i love him and i
know he's hurting but i can't fix all
that i'm going to let him carry his own
deal
and here's his backpack and i don't want
to be it just uh
just you know oh yeah there's walgreens
john
john talks about that all the time the
bricks in the backpack that we carry
around from other people putting them in
there and we're wondering why we can't
even crawl yeah that's exactly what it
is yeah exactly what's going on here so
yeah you can do this man you really can
and if you need some more help you call
back anytime we're here to talk to you
and give ken coleman a call on his show
yeah be a fun one yeah on the career
side yeah um
we'll we'll always tell you the truth
but um i i just kind of hear it and
um you know when you don't have uh when
you don't physically feel great because
of the heart thing going on it makes it
triple hard to fight through the other
stuff
so it's a mental exercise of tough
mental toughness for you to move through
these other areas controlling the things
you can control and then things start to
move for you and let go of the rest
that's exactly it
hey thank you for calling sir hang on
we'll get you all those materials out to
you and try to help you any way we can